Annihilation is a new sci-fi movie based on
a book by Jeff VanderMeer. It’s about an
alien place that grows and mutates and about
the people who it changes. It explores themes
of life and death, raises some cool mysteries,
and builds on the ideas of the book. The story
follows an expedition into the mysterious
Area X – a wilderness surrounded by a strange
“border” called the Shimmer . Anyone who
enters doesn’t return and the border is
growing . The team in the movie includes the
biologist Lena, the psychologist Ventress,
and the scientists Josie, Cass and Anya.
Together they enter the Area, and they find
mutant lifeforms like these colourful growths,
and strange hybrid creatures, like a plant
with different species of flower, an alligator
with teeth like a shark , and a man with slithering
snake-like guts. There are plants growing
in human shapes, and a mutant bear creature
that speaks with Cass’ voice after it kills
her. So the Area makes new lifeforms by merging
existing ones together.
But there’s also duplication, making copies
of things – there’s a mutant deer that
mimics another deer’s movement. There’s
a double of Lena, which copies her movement
and her face. And we learn that Lena’s husband
Kane who returned from Area X is actually
an alien copy of the real Kane, who committed
suicide. The Area duplicates other stuff too.
Like, by the end of the movie, Lena gets a
tattoo that she didn’t have at the beginning.
It starts out as a bruise, but develops into
this ouroboros design – a copy of the same
tattoo on Anya and on this dead guy. The ouroboros
symbolises a cycle of life and death. There’s
also a house in Area X that looks just like
Lena’s place back home. So the Area doesn’t
just duplicate animals, it duplicates images,
and even places based on memories.
The Area affects light and radio and magnetism,
it affects the team’s minds , it even affects
time – the team loses a few days at the
start . So the Area distorts, duplicates,
merges, mutates, and creates in a process
Josie calls refraction . And it all seems
to come from some alien presence in this lighthouse
. The movie shows that it’s extraterrestrial
– there’re shots of a meteor coming from
space and hitting the lighthouse. We don’t
know what the alien wants, or if it wants
at all – the movie suggests it’s like
a cancer, unthinking cells that just grow
and spread .
So while the alien in this movie represents
growth, the humans represent self-destruction.
Ventress says “almost all of us self-destruct”,
it’s “coded into us” . Each character
hurts themselves somehow – Josie cuts herself
. Anya is “an addict” . Ventress has cancer
, and enters the Area as a sort of suicide.
Lena has an affair with her douchey work colleague
who she hates , which hurts her relationship
with her husband Kane who she loves. And Kane
knows about Lena’s affair, which might be
partly why he volunteered for a dangerous
mission to Area X. Even this tattoo represents
self-destruction – it’s a snake eating
itself – destroying itself. So the humans
in this movie self-destruct – and this is
actually how they beat the alien in the end.
Lena gives a grenade to the alien double that’s
mimicking her – she teaches it to blow itself
up. And the alien learns this self-destruction,
because that’s is its function – to duplicate
and assimilate. It assimilates its own annihilation.
So – the double burns, and takes the lighthouse
and Shimmer down with it. Humanity beats the
alien not through heroics or strength, but
through our own flaws and weakness.
At the end of the movie, Lena reunites with
Kane, who she now knows is actually an alien
clone. And the Kane asks whether she is really
Lena . The movie ends with Lena’s eyes glowing
bright, which implies some kinda alien juju.
So maybe this Lena is actually an alien clone.
Maybe the Shimmer didn’t really fall, it
just expanded to include the whole world.
The ending is deliberately ambiguous, but
this Lena probably is the real Lena. Cause
we saw the mimic Lena burn, and the real Lena
had been infected with glowing mutation from
early on – the glow’s nothing new. So
the ending might not mean that Lena is an
alien, it means that human Lena has changed.
She taught the alien how to self-destruct
– maybe the alien taught her to grow.
So the movie’s an exploration of life and
death, growth and change. The book explores
similar ideas, but the story’s quite different.
Like, Area X in the book doesn’t create
much new mutant life – it’s more about
assimilation. People who enter the Area are
transformed to become part of the natural
environment – so there’s a dolphin with
a human eye , and a fox made of human cells,
as well as these creepy plant people . The
Area absorbs everything into itself , and
it spreads, by expanding its border, and by
sending out clones to replace humans . The
mimicry and doubling is maybe like a “camouflage”
used to hide its slow growth to replace everything
with an alien copy .
And the book hints at a kind of intelligence
behind this. Like, in the movie, the lighthouse
has a spooky H. R. Giger alien basement, but
the book has a whole tunnel structure separate
to the lighthouse. It’s like an alien upside-down
copy of the lighthouse. And it has a long
spiral staircase descending down, with a fungus
forming words on the walls. It reads “Where
lies the strangling fruit that came from the
hand of the sinner I shall bring forth the
seeds of the dead” and it goes on and on
like that. It’s as though the alien is trying
to absorb human ideas as well as human bodies.
The spiralling shape of the words looks kinda
like DNA. And the border is like a cell wall,
a membrane. So the whole Area seems kinda
like a biological cell. Which lends itself
to the cancer metaphor – a tumour growing
on the world.
In the book, none of the characters have names
– they’re just called the biologist, the
psychologist, anthropologist and surveyor.
Their relationships are more cold, and suspicious.
The psychologist uses hypnotism to control
the others – makes them forget things, and
limits what they see . The government agency,
the Southern Reach, is super mysterious and
manipulative. They lie to the group , withhold
information – it’s almost like they’re
experimenting on the expedition members as
much as on the Area . And the protagonist,
the biologist, is a complicated, highly introverted
character – she’s sometimes an unreliable
narrator who misleads the reader . So the
book is super psychological, tense and paranoid.
But it’s also about the environment. For
all the drama and mystery, the story is also
a love letter to the beauty and the strangeness
of nature.
So if you wanna go deeper into Area X, you
can listen to the Annihilation novel now for
free at audible.com/asx. As our sponsor, Audible’s
offering an audiobook of your choice with
a free trial – and they have thousands of
audiobooks on offer. If you’ve already read
Annihilation, you might like the little-known
Game of Thrones series, and its spin-off books
like Dunk & Egg and the worldbook. To check
em out, sign up at audible.com/asx, or text
asx to 500-500.
Thanks to maddyasma for this lighthouse artwork,
and thanks to the Patrons, including Skyler
Rudolfsky, Candace Brooke, matt hankel, and
KEKmaster. Cheers.